on this episode we talked to doc AII
about how they're bringing the power to
the people
when it comes to medical research
actually thank you so much for joining
us you tell us a little more about what
doc a is first of all thank you for
having me happy to share one tockia is
so doc here is a digital health company
designed for a new generation of medical
research and what that really means is
that today the world of medical research
is very localized to your doctor's
deciding where you the patient should be
sort of ushered into for clinical trials
on what type of drugs that you should be
on so what we are seeing is that
patients and generally users aren't
involved in the world of medical
research
they don't have agency to make decisions
so with taki i we are building a bunch
of ecosystems of tools including a taki
a companion medical research app but
also other tools and technologies using
artificial intelligence that allows
patients to take ownership of their own
data and also be able to decide what
type of medical research that they want
to participate all through their mobile
app so you mentioned AI what aspect of
AI are you bringing to the users who are
using a platform it's a great question
so I think what we care about is how can
users collect medical segments and
medical information and capture all of
this data on their mobile phone using
their mobile phone so what that means is
that we can use different components of
a phone like for example your camera but
also your voice
also things like chat BOTS so we invest
in a lot of tools and technologies that
help us sort of rule out different AI
components for data capture we are also
investing in quite a bit in privacy and
security preserving tools and
technologies like federated learning
along with differential privacy so that
we can keep their data on the phone but
still use the data on the phone to train
models that can give a global
perspective of
a nation without actually ever sending
their data no sir
so that's a lot of different pieces that
you're covering as a company how does
this kind of relate to health care as an
industry right so I think what we see
with health care is that without members
and participants being part of the
health care we are not going to get
enough information about the progression
of different diseases or we are not
going to make progress in terms of
research so an important aspect of
healthcare is how do we get patients and
users involved in research so one aspect
of this is data collection so with the
doc here medical app what we have built
is multi-omics polyamic way of
collecting data so examples of that is
we could collect your genomics data and
keep the data on the phone we could
collect your medical records your
pharmacy records your medication pill
bottles your lab records but also newer
types of information like how how about
your location and how does that impact
your health we call it exposomics so we
all we need is your GPS location we can
keep that on the phone for you if you
want and still be able to understand it
so we invest quite a bit in different
and new types of data collection through
consumer mediation on the other side
what we want to do is be able to like
care all of this data through the right
consent and often and correlate
information across different types of
data and call it the Palio mix data
combination problem so be able to
understand how does your genomics
information influence based on regular
so I think this will change the way it
influences healthcare for other players
in the ecosystem by having wider
adoption of participants and members and
patients stay tuned for more great
conversations of talk AI if you enjoyed
this episode
check out the SPAC chat playlist for
more great videos
you